wir testen uns durch die besten food
Spots in Amsterdam und eins kann ich
euch sagen Amsterdam ist wirklich auf
einem anderen Level deshalb los geht's
zum ersten Spot
[Musik]
wir starten unseren Tag wie so oft mit
einem richtig guten Kaffee aber der wird
heute begleitet von einem pistakio
crafin also einer Pistazien Croissant
Waffel was einfach nur geil sein kann
deshalb stellen ein bisschen Zeit muss
man mitbringen aber es wird sich lohnen
[Musik]
das hier ist was man morgens sehen will
schöner Kaffee und dazu das Objekt der
begierdet alle haben gerade in der
Schlange darauf gewartet ein
ich habe bisher nur auf Social Media von
craftings gehört noch nie in der Hand
gehabt das ist eine Mischung aus einem
Croissant und ein Muffin und in der
Mitte haben wir diese pistaziencreme
hört mal bitte
11:30 Uhr kamen sie aus dem Ofen wir
haben jetzt 11:40 Uhr
Kaffee sehr gut rein in den
[Musik]
wow dieses pistaziencreme in der Mitte
schmeckt richtig krass nach so
gerösteten Pistazien man sieht auch
sogar noch einzelne Stücke drin wenn man
in Süditalien Urlaub macht kennt auf
jeden Fall diese pistaziencreme und das
hier ist eine richtig gute und das in
einem knusprigen aber wirklich vor allem
fluffigen Croissant Teig ist halt
einfach unfair ne manche Sachen die man
kennt Aktivkohle Burger Band sind
einfach Schrott aber ein crafting hat
echt eine da sein Berechtigung und wenn
ihr ein Amsterdam seid dann holt euch
einen weil es einfach wirklich krass
lecker
meine Lust auf Süßes ist noch nicht ganz
gestillt und ich stehe vor Winkel 43
einem lebhaften Kaffee das für seinen
Apfelkuchen bekannt ist den kriegt man
an vielen Orten in Amsterdam aber ich
habe gehört hier gibt's den besten
[Musik]
guckt euch diese Schönheit einfach mal
an original typischer niederländischer
Apfelkuchen mit einer schönen großen die
schon fast aussieht wie ein Keks innen
drin Apfelstückchen mit einem zimtmantel
außenrum und eine ordentlicher
Schlagsahne 5,60 € kostet das gute Stück
für Amsterdam Verhältnisse absolut fair
ich nehme hier vorne in der Ecke ein
bisschen Sahne ein bisschen Kuchen
[Musik]
das ist so einfach aber so gut also der
schmeckt wirklich schön zimtig die
Apfelstücke unnormal geil dass du die
Sahne ich glaube das gefällt wirklich
jedem was besonders auffällt ist diese
leichte Zimtnote ich meine jedes Land
hat ja seinen eigenen Apfelkuchen Sascha
deutscher Blech Apfelkuchen dann gibt es
den Apple crumble und das ist wirklich
sehr sehr gute Variante das muss man den
Holländern lassen wenn ich so ein Teil
bestellt noch mehr essen wollt am Tag
dann holt euch besser Begleitung
boah
der schmeckt echt richtig geil
[Musik]
wir befinden uns vom maijahr Smash
Burgers benannt nach der maja-reaktion
die passiert wenn sich eine schöne
Kruste beim Braten entwickelt was darum
Chris und einfach schöne Burger werden
uns hier hinten versprochen reden wir
nicht lange und holen uns sein
[Musik]
das lässt mein burgerherz höher schlagen
leute guckt euch das einfach mal an ein
selbstgebackenes potato Bann wunderschön
weich hauchdünniges mehrstück Patties
unten Käse feiner Eisbergsalat und
selbstgemachte Soßen dazu noch ein paar
hausgemachte Gewürzgurken sowas sucht
man vergebens bei mir in Köln klar in
Berlin gibt es Goldies unglaublich gut
aber der hier sieht gefährlich aus also
packen wir den jungen Mann mal aus
der Smash war noch nicht kennt durch das
Märchen kriegt man maximale Kruste und
maximale röstet darum ist einfach nur
benutzen rein da
vor die hausgemachte Soße hat wirklich
Züge von der Big Mac Sauce auf eine Art
und Weise ist überhaupt kein dann das
matchberger also das ist wirklich eine
ganz andere Liga
von Herzen empfehlen und dazu gibt es
hier Smash potatos da liegen einfach so
kleine Drillinge so kleine Kartoffeln
mit einer Soße und frisch geriebenem
Käse getoppt werden
so heißen
oben drauf
die sind richtig richtig
schön knusprig
einfach genau das was ich jetzt
gebraucht habe nach den zwei süßen Spots
Amsterdam hat es wirklich kulinarisch
einfach sowas von drauf auch so kleiner
Fläche also in der Innenstadt so viele
Kranke Fußballs glaub mir dass das noch
nicht alles war
[Musik]
hinter mir ist Farbe Fried einer der
gehyptesten Läden in Amsterdam bei dem
es einfach nur Pommes gibt gehen wir
rein und finden heraus warum sie so gut
sind
[Musik]
wir stehen hier in der Schlange und die
Schlange ist nicht hier sondern
eigentlich da vorne und sie wird
aufgeteilt weil sie häufig so lange ist
wir ein bisschen Glück weil wir relativ
früh da sind aber auch hier kann es sein
dass man eine Stunde warten muss und das
ist wirklich eine der down-seits von
Amsterdam bei den krassen Spots wartest
du einfach also touristisch ist und die
Leute wissen mittlerweile wo es gutes
Essen gibt ich weiß nicht wann in meinem
Leben ich so viel Aufwand für eine
einfache Portion Pommes betrieben hat
und ich frag mich ob sie den halbwert
sind ich nehme einfach eine und wir
essen das ganze Parmesan Trüffel Mario
der gehört das ist die einzige richtige
Bestellung die man hier tätigen soll ich
probiere
also sind durch krank gute Pommes
unfassbar viel kann man dazu nicht sagen
die sind knusprig du hast aber trotzdem
gar nicht von Hand geschnitten werden
auch die kleinen Stücke noch einfach nur
knusprig sind auch perfekt gesalzen ne
nicht irgendwie so ein bisschen boah die
ist schon sexy Neo du hattest gestern
auf einer anderen Pommesbude welche die
sind schon wahrscheinlich ne
5,90 € so wie sie hier habe also mit
Parmesan und Trüffel finde ich auch fair
für Amsterdam der Laden selbst ist
wirklich besonders winzig klein da
stehen acht Jungs drin oder so alle
zwischen 18 und 20 die nichts anderes
machen als diese wilden Pommes hier und
wieso häufig ist es einfach so dass ein
einladen sich nur auf ein Produkt
konzentriert dann ist es auch krass und
ja diese Möbel wird probieren unsere
Pommes zu tun
unglaublich gute Pommes fairer Preis so
gut dass sogar die Möwen sie haben
wollen
wissen die Leute was
abgeht unheimlich viele von euch auch
vorgeschlagen haben deshalb danke schön
an der Stelle und äh schaut mal auf
Instagram vorbei dann könnt ihr mir
immer gute Tipps geben danke schön jetzt
brauche ich mal was zu essen
[Musik]
hinter mir ist Frenzel das heißt es gibt
Kibbeling ist Chicken Nuggets mit Fisch
mit Kabeljau zu sein ja genau ich esse
Nuggets aus Kabeljau das Hemd dass ich
trage blau die rote Farbe auch bestellen
[Musik]
schönen Ausbackteig goldbraun frittiert
dazu eine Soße und Kräuter Knoblauch
Mayo Sauce und auch hier ihr seht im
Hintergrund kann eine kleine Schlange da
sein wir hatten gerade keine die jetzt
innerhalb von einer Minute gebildet und
riecht auch nicht so altes Öl sondern
das ist gute Qualität ich gehe einmal
rein in die Source ich habe ein bisschen
Angst vor der Temperatur der hat das
gerade aus der Fritteuse geholt egal
einfach rein
ja crazy oder geil gewürzt saftig genug
Wasser drin wirklich also das glänzt der
richtige Panade guck mal das ist ein
Millimeter hat so ein immensen Krampf
richtig das macht Spaß beim Essen
passiert Alter
Amsterdam wäre es nicht weiß ist lost
aber liegt ja auch direkt am Meer ne
direkt aber ist mehr wird hier
reingezogen also ist auf jeden Fall
davon auszugehen dass das mit frischem
Fisch zubereitet wird und es schmeckt
gut es ist knusprig es ist lecker es ist
warm es ist vor allem aber auch
Tradition und Dutch Food und sogar die
besten mögen es wie gesagt deshalb weiß
ich nicht warum ihr es nicht auch mögen
würden
jetzt vielleicht oder ja warum nicht ich
will noch eine Sache sagen ich glaube
das geht ein bisschen unter inmitten von
diesen ausnahmslos krassen Essen jeder
Spot in diesem Video
also ist wirklich unfassbar gut dieser
killing ich habe noch nie sowas gut
gegessen noch nicht so guten frittierten
Fisch gehabt Smash Burger
federanzeige sowas kriegst du in Köln
nicht wir haben Sachen noch heute diese
Cookies die später noch kommen werden
ich habe Angst davor und ich bin froh
dass ich heute Abend weg bin aus
Amsterdam weil das Essen ist zu krass
[Musik]
bevor wir zum Finale kommen mit dem
Cookies noch ein letztes mal herzhaft
und nicht irgendwie ihr werdet
vielleicht im letzten Video gesehen
haben
leverbot bei Bestellung frisch gebacken
auf einem satch Ofen das ist so ein
Halbkreis auf den Teiglinge gelegt
werden knusprig ausgepacken von einer
Seite die andere bleibt schön weich dann
wird das Ganze gefüllt gestrichen mit
guten Zutaten habe ich zum ersten Mal
vor vier fünf Jahren gegessen immer wenn
ich in Amsterdam das gehen wir rein und
lass uns schmecken
[Musik]
wir wollten es mir gerade schenken aber
ich habe gesagt ich will dafür bezahlen
weil das ist einfach so lecker und so
besonders wir haben einen Sauerteig
satchbrot das frisch gebacken wird innen
drin haben wir dieses weiche Beef mit
Granatapfelsirup Tomaten Minze und
Lappen also so ein Frischkäse und das
schmeckt einfach
meine deutliche Ecke krasser und das
Brot hat eine perfekte Konsistenz das
kommt wirklich schon mal ganz anders als
geliefert dieses marinierte Fleisch hat
und orientalisch libanesischen gewürzmix
es schmeckt einfach unglaublich gut ich
habe keinen Vergleich für euch das ist
einzigartig aber wenn ihr hier seid
vertraut mir könnt euch das so
das was sie hinter mir seht ist die
Schlange für einen Cookie ihr habt
richtig gehört für einen Cookie der
nichts anderes als diesen einen Cookie
gibt es bei der funstable gucken makerei
der so bekannt dass die Menschen diese
Straße hier besetzen und wir waren
schlau und haben ihn im Vorfeld bestellt
wir haben sie fun Star appmakerei ich
hoffe ich spreche richtig aus gucken
wenn man drüber nachdenkt unvorstellbar
vor allen Dingen wenn man überlegt dass
da gerade 150 Menschen drauf war die
kommen immer frisch aus dem Ofen während
ich das so halte merke ich auch die sind
noch so leicht warm und hier drin 6er
Pack für 12:50 Uhr sind die begehrten
Kekse mit einer Anweisung wie man sie
ideal wieder aufwärmen kann das
ungeschulte Auge könnte sie vielleicht
auf den ersten Blick gar nicht von
Subway Cookies unterscheiden ich sag's
jetzt einfach was ich denke auch wenn es
eine Beleidigung ist aber wow warm
fettig in der Mitte der Kern aus weißer
Schokolade wir probieren das ganze
erstmal ich kann mir jetzt diesen wissen
und ich erwarte wirklich nicht viel ich
erwarte alles von diesem Cookie
Menschen sagen dass ich Heroin so
anfühlt als sei man wieder im Bauch der
eigenen Mutter und alles wäre in Ordnung
Tom diese Cookies sind Heroin das ist
eine Wärme die den Körper durchströmt
das kitzelt so an deiner Kopfhaut es ist
wirklich das ist der krasseste Cookie
den ich je gegessen habe weißt du was
ich halt auch direkt hatte dieser
Kontrast das ist halt außen wirklich bis
hat und innen drin noch so halb roh ist
gefühlt die restlichen 4 nehme ich jetzt
mal mit nach Hause es schönes Andenken
an diesem wunderschönen Amsterdam Trip
der kulinarisch einiges bisher da
gewesen ist im Schatten gestellt hat
ich hoffe ihr hattet genauso viel Spaß
wie wir sehen uns beim nächsten Video
wieder bis dahin macht's gut ciao ciao
meine Füße so raus und dann machst du so
auf den Wolkenkratzer
bitte